Harley Quinn might still be relatively
new to DC Comics but she's already gone
through some significant style ships in
the years since her debut when
moviegoers got to see if that character
in Suicide Squad was just a sliver of
her story here's a rundown of the most
significant moments in Harley's
evolution Batman the Animated Series in
1992 Harley Quinn made her debut as the
Joker's right-hand gal in Batman the
Animated Series the character was
inspired by a surreal Harlequin scene
from days of our lives featuring actors
Arleen Sorkin an old friend a writer
producer Paul Dini when Dini saw the
scene he knew exactly who he wanted as
the Joker's new sidekick he recruited
Sorkin herself to do that characters
voice her original ensemble was designed
by artist Bruce Timm and remains her
most iconic costume early appearances
Harley made her comic book debut in
Batman adventures number 12 maintaining
much of the same look as her animated
appearance as the details of her
seduction by the Joker became a focal
point specifically in Batman adventures
mad love she started to show a little
more shape and a little more sass in
December 2000 she got her first comics
series where she temporarily drops her
relationship with the Joker choosing
poison ivy instead the new series made
her more realistic but it still kept her
costume the same for its full run Arkham
Asylum
Harley sex appeal made its first real
appearance in the 2009 video game Batman
Arkham Asylum making her barely
recognizable her backstory remains
similar but her look was sharply
different blonde pigtails are revealing
corset and thigh high boots
she was also not as light-hearted as
she'd once been Dini who also wrote the
game defends her controversial changes
saying well I wanted to make it clear
that Harley Quinn was out of her mind
you know that I always thought there was
a spark between this this new version of
Harley would also appear in the rest of
the Arkham series each time appearing
slightly different the new 52 when DC
rebooted the Suicide Squad comics as
part of its new 52 event hardly got a
major style overhaul introducing her red
and blue pigtails corset hot pants and
heel
the series also revamped our origin
story to include the chemical skin
alterations later seen in the cinematic
version soon after that first
stand-alone series got its own reboot
and ushered in the era of blue and pink
eye shadow although the colors of her
costume and hair hearken back to her
signature red and black fur midriff legs
and more were still on full display
Suicide Squad the cinematic Suicide
Squad followed suit and displaying
Hartley's allure on-screen in the flick
Margot Robbie's Harley also sported
pigtails partially dyed blue and pink
tiny shorts at a dirty shirt red varsity
jacket a ton of tattoos and boots while
the getup paid tribute to the past
versions of the character it also
arrived as its own new spin Bruce Timm
Harley's original designer told Gizmodo
that the characters new design looked
quote really cool Dini
meanwhile thought the daddy's monster
approach was a good way to make it work
I know it's jarring for a lot of the
people who loved the the classic Bruce
Timm suit I love it myself I mean it but
in that work fold I just don't see it
happening the changes have since been
incorporated into DC's rebirth
initiative launched in the summer of
2016 this new Harley Quinn has the
screen versions hair style makeup and a
much more urbanized garment game who
keeping up with all those style changes
can be well vexing I'm known to be quite
vexing I'm just forewarning you thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which is your favorite
Harley Quinn costume